[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages come then to see
what's making the headlines with the
former Scottish labor leader Kezia
dugdale and the deputy editor of
conservative home Henry Hill welcome to
both of you so from Pages let's start
shall we with the guardian it leads with
growing calls for an investigation into
how the self-confessed rapist David
Carrick was allowed to be a metropolitan
police officer while the Daily Mail
reports that despite his crimes Carrick
may still be allowed to keep his 22 000
pound annual police pension something
the mayor of London wants to stop
the Metro has word of industrial action
across multiple sectors on February the
1st as rail staff teachers University
lecturers and silver servants across a
number of government departments all
stop work while the Daily Mirror claims
that rather than pay nurses a fair wage
the government is offering 40 pounds an
hour to people willing to cross their
picket lines according to the eye the
business secretary Grant shaps has said
he is opposed to forcibly installing
energy prepayment meters in the homes of
people who fail to keep up with their
bills the express has word from the
Prime Minister that his so-called
bonfire of EU regulations will be a
major boost to the UK's economic growth
the telegraph leads with concerns
expressed by the equality Minister that
a ban on trans conversion therapy must
not be used
to criminalize parents of trans children
the front of the times carries a warning
from the boss of the food standards
agency about the dangers of bringing
cake into the office apparently just as
harmful as passive smoking the paper
reports
the financial times reports that the
international monetary fund is upgrading
its economic Outlook amid science that
the global economy is starting to show
signs of improvement
and because we like to bring a mix of
stories the star says a republican
congressman from Tennessee is insisting
that Joe Biden has covered up hundreds
UFO sightings and that there's proof for
his allegations in the Bible
not to be outdone the sun says Sports
presenter Gary lenica was drowned out by
sound effects from a porn film during an
onset prank
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out those front pages of
the most newspapers while you watch us
so let's head straight to Our Guest then
Kezia dugdale and Henry Hill who are
with us
um and Henry let's start with the Metro
shall we it's one out all out we've
always wondered whether a strike action
would coalesce um and February the 1st
this paper suggests is the day
yes absolutely so it looks like what's
happening is across the uh public sector
multiple trades unions representing
teachers nurses Railway staff civil
servants and others are coordinating
their strike action effectively so that
it all takes place on the same day now
this might not be as bad for the
government as you initially think there
was an interesting line I think in one
of the papers about the the nurses
saying that actually whether the
teachers have gone on strike on a
different day we'd probably have had to
stay home anyway because of the child
care crisis so that would have
immediately created but nonetheless it
is a sign that this problem isn't going
away and it will obviously make us
strike action more visible you know if
you're a parent uh who also has to get
to work and all of a sudden not only is
your kids school shut but your your
commuter train isn't running and all the
rest of it it will really drive home the
scale of the industrial action currently
facing the country and its impact on
public services yes your thoughts on
that Kezia while we weave in the
telegraph which is about how head
teachers will you know plan around the
the teaching strike the telegraph
suggesting that head teachers are
refusing to put in place contingency
measures that could limit the impact of
Staff walkouts question is whether they
will or their Union will rebalot again
to see if they'll also take strike
action so yeah your thoughts
yes it shouldn't surprise us that the
Jade unions are working collectively
together to enhance the pressure on the
UK government to settle a series of pay
disputes they've been rumbling on for
several months it's a principle of the
labor movement that by the strength of
your common Endeavor you can achieve
more together than you can alone and
that's what we're going to see on the
1st of February this story in the
telegraph however about the Royal head
teachers I find really fascinating so I
don't think that the union representing
head teachers are yet to say that
there's an entity are about to go out
and strike but what they are talking
about here is the degree to which they
are prepared to be involved in strike
breaking activities just how prepared
they are to facilitate schools still
functioning the absence of teachers and
classroom assistants and other support
staff that help the schools run it looks
very much like they're going to be on
the side of the teachers in supporting
that industrial action rather than
bidding themselves and doing everything
they can to try and make things continue
as normal I think that shows that
there's a great deal of Sympathy for the
strike action in fact repeated public
polling shows that the public are on the
majority side of backing the trade
unions and pay deals for public sectors
and that can only bring further
headaches for the UK government yes and
certainly figures today Henry that
showed public sector pay increases are
indeed lagging behind the private sector
I know everyone brings in the pensions
at this point but notwithstanding that
so why isn't the government now moving
Heaven and Earth you know to meet these
unions and try and try to resolve this
because you can't keep going at this can
you
no they can't and although you you have
flagged it I think the easiest win for
the government would be to make an offer
that said look if we reduced your
mandatory pension contributions allow
you to take more of that as cash that is
that is a relatively simple way they
could increase monthly take-home pay for
a lot of these workers the government is
in a tricky position because this round
of this round of pay demands is really
just a shadow of what's going to come
next year because the independent pay
bodies that the government uses to it
has based its positions on their
information their their projections did
not take into account the level of
inflation that we've seen over the last
few months the next set of projections
this year will which means the
government knows that this year it's
going to have to settle another round of
pay demands next year now the big
problem for the government the
structural problem is that there is
already not enough money taxes are as
high as they've been in a very long time
lots of Public Services are running
um on fumes and the more money that gets
sucked into into pay effectively is less
money that you can spend on Capital
Investments and Innovation and so on but
on the other side of the coin this is
where I think government's sort of tough
really tough strike wrestler it doesn't
really work you do ultimately need
people to be prepared to work in these
industries and they do need to be paid a
decent wage the the slightly fatuous
comparison with Margaret Thatcher I
think was often drawn by some
conservative MPS Margaret Thatcher was
pushing towards you know the basically
the end of an industry right there was a
clear end point at which point the num
would no longer be relevant that's not
the case here even if in the best case
scenario if the government somehow broke
the strike we'd still need nurses we'd
still need train drivers we'd still need
teachers all of these issues would
remain so I think the government's
problem is it's trapped between not
having a strategy and the public having
a lot of support for the strikers and
the blunt fact that there is simply not
enough money to keep supporting the
current size of the British State yeah I
mean that's fascinating isn't it now the
cost of the NHS is often raised at that
point uh the Royal College of Nursing to
pick one example suggesting they'd meet
the government halfway it's 10 still too
much for the government to afford do you
think Kezia because of the idea of baked
in wage inflation
no I don't think it's too much and my
rationale for that is simply to point
you to what NHS boards the length and
Bridge of the country are paying in the
form of agency staff wages at the point
where they don't have
um nurses or on their payroll or on
their workforces paying three four
sometimes six times the average hourly
wage that a nurse receives on bank
holidays for example to fill the gaps we
are spending inordinate amounts of money
trying to redress problems that come
down to poor workforce planning the
inability to recruit enough nurses in
the first place and I'm sorry to be the
first person to mention the word tonight
but brexit has had a huge impact on our
National Health Service and our ability
to recruit the staff we need for it to
run which means the staff who are left
there are underpaid with great deal of
Demands on their time and on their
energies than they've ever faced before
and that's why they're at their wit's
end that's why nurses are striking for
the first time in a hundred years that's
how serious this is and how
persistent they are in their demands for
a decent pay rise okay we'll certainly
keep an eye on what happens on Feb the
1st and indeed this week with more
strikes due but let's move on shall we
Henry to
um a story that is horrified many
including the Prime Minister as we heard
today
um appalled he called it the Guardians
leading on this as well uh about the
former we can now say met police officer
David Carrick
um and the questions about why he was
allowed to stay in position so long and
should there be an a proper inquiry
um into officers who allowed him to stay
in the med Henry
I mean yeah yes they should there are so
many things that are absolutely
horrifying about this story you know the
specifics of of the band's crimes
obviously first and foremost but you
read about it and you read about how
basically so many of these are police
officers are saying oh yeah we knew he
was we knew he was a robin
um he had a reputation as a wrong and
it's like well how did nothing happen
how are we in a position where an
institution which relies on public trust
you know the police absolutely rely on
public trust to do their job allowed a
man like this to stay in post because
what he did he didn't just by abusing
his position as a police officer to to
attack women he didn't just commit those
individual crimes that stained the
uniform you look at the you look on the
internet you look at the reaction to
this story and what you're seeing is
women who are saying how am I ever going
to trust the police and that's awful
that's a huge societal harm that this
man in the actions of men like him have
done so absolutely it's it's past time
at this point there was a proper root
and Branch clear out in the met and any
other affected force and we need much
more rigorous procedures in place to
make sure that these officers are
drummed out and properly punished and
that if they're not people are held
accountable for that failure yes in a
two-hour hearing today
um you know to strip him of his job you
know even that wasn't straightforward
Kezia uh well the Daily Mail says what
happens to his pension
um you know that surely has to go too
yes this is the astonishing reality that
he may be entitled to keep his 22 000
pound final salary pension simply
because the heinous crimes that he
committed were committed off duty out
with of uniform I think everybody in the
country will be pretty shocked to hear
that and want some pretty urgent
resolution too let me just add do I
agree with every single word that Henry
has said there and this man has become a
very unfortunate poster boy for a much
deeper problem in the metropolitan
police we're talking here about over a
thousand different officers being
investigated for over 1600 different
types of offense in the Realms of sexual
offense or domestic violence that that's
not just a problem that's an endemic
problem and it does feel like we've been
here before that we've heard promises
from senior police leaders that will be
a written Branch review that will learn
lessons that things will happen so every
time they do that the Public's
willingness to believe that things will
actually change I think depreciates
putting even more pressure sure on Mark
Riley the chief Police Superintendent to
do something really quite dramatic here
and what Harry Harmon's been calling for
today is to say well look it's not
enough just to pursue the people who've
committed offenses we should also be
pursuing the people that knew about it
and did nothing to that bystander
approach is a new angle on this very
very long-standing story yes absolutely
and the the Home Secretary Sawa bravman
suggesting that she was braced for more
shocking cases to emerge in the wake of
the uh David Carrick Scandal
um lots of the focus has been on how to
improve things via vetting vetting
becoming more meaningful Henry
um but but in the telegraph article the
suggestion to that the Home Secretary
would make it or is considering making
it easier for chief constables to sack
corrupt or abusive officers
yeah I think the second is especially
important better betting is always good
but but fundamentally there's only so
much that vetting can do because
obviously you know this man had not
committed his offenses and given that he
exploited his position as a police
officer had not had an opportunity to to
perpetrate his crimes before he became a
police officer so what you need is yes
you need vetting but you need to make
sure that there are really robust and
stringent mechanisms in place for
identifying this for encouraging
um other police officers to come forward
for having maybe a confidential way that
they can do that and then for making
sure that all those complaints are
properly followed up like we've all seen
cop shows are normally you know that the
people from internal affairs all the
cops hate them they hate other cops and
so on but but fundamentally it's really
really important that the the public
bodies we entrust with with especially
with policing right with exercising
Force you know he was an armed officer
he's one of the very few people that
this country allows to carry a gun it's
really important that those institutions
are policed more rigorously and actually
one thing I think the government should
consider doing is actually introduce
saying I and I don't really you do this
often because we have an awful lot of
criminal offenses but I think that that
abuse of the of the uniform and conduct
in a way that actually as I said earlier
degrades The public's faith in
institutions like the police should be
either a new criminal offense or it
should be a really strong compounding
factor in sentencing so that you know
it's right I think to hold police
officers to a higher standard if they
commit crimes they should do more time
than people who've done the same thing
as civilians um so we move on to gender
recognition and conversion therapy uh so
Kezia what exactly is conversion therapy
and what are the concerns being
expressed in the daily telegraphs lead
story
so these are two separate stories rolled
into one front page one is about banning
conversion therapy and I'll explain that
in a second and the other is about the
UK government's response to the passing
of the gender recognition Reform Act in
the Scottish Parliament conversion
therapy bluntly is where you seek to try
and cure people of their sexuality but
that's what you would describe it if you
were talking about and gay conversion
therapy and there's also a version of it
to try and dissuade people from changing
their gender now this has been an issue
the conservatives have grappled with for
a number of years and changed their
position on a number of times and
largely driven by some views that can be
bad enough amounts others have had about
it so what she's doing in some very
interesting timing aligning this
announcement at the same time as the
developing story in Scotland around
gender recognition is to say that yes
they will ban conversion therapy as it
applies to both gay people and to trans
people and but they will have some extra
clarification around the Banning of the
trans conversion to ADP to raise your
religious groups and indeed parents that
nothing that they would do to perhaps
try and dissuade their children from
changing their gender would lead to them
being criminalized as parents for trying
to do that particular thing for their
child that all comes down to the
definition in the law of what conversion
therapy actually is and looks like but
there's no doubt it's an appeasement to
the kind of right and far out of the
conservative party if you will see this
as real dilution of what was originally
attended in conservative party policy
okay and then we move on to the battle
between Hollywood and Westminster over
Scotland's gender recognition
legislation the story in the Metro that
takes a slightly different tag which is
at what age is it appropriate for you to
determine your own gender now the labor
leader sakistan had expressed concerns
about the age of 16 whereas we heard
from Julian Keegan in fact speaking on
Sky News saying that 16 was not too
young for people to decide to change
gender anyway lots has come out of this
not least the year the battle which
we're expecting with Hollywood Henry
absolutely
um Julian Keegan has I imagine after
some strict words from Downing Street
wrote back on her comments to an extent
for me I think the most interesting
thing about them really is that all of
the things that she listed that she
could do at 16. most of them you can't
do now right you know we she she says
well you like to call it 16 I think you
know how to be in uh education to 18 law
the law is going to change very soon I
think so that you can only get married
at 18. so the UK really is in a model in
general over the age over the age of
consent that the battle in Scotland is
basically the UK government has said has
for the first time I think ever invoked
section 35 of the Scotland act 1998
which basically allows the the UK
government to block legislation passed
by the Scottish government uh the
Scottish Parliament if it thinks that
that legislation negatively impacts
uk-wide important uk-y policy now the
equality act 2010 which is the career
which is basically don't have to rush
you've only got 10 seconds left could
you just draw it to him
the equality act the equality Act is a
reserved piece of legislation British
government thinks undermine it and has
blocked the legislation Sterling is
going to challenge it